the founding fathers of the united
states
are they
um individualists or are they
conservatives
so in this particular revolution they
founded this country at the core of
which are some
fascinating some powerful ideas
were those founding fathers were those
ideas coming from a place of
conservatism or did they put
primary value into the freedom and the
power of the individual what do you
think
there were both
i mean this is i this is something
that's a little bit difficult for
sometimes for for for americans i mean
even very educated americans they they
they talk about the founding fathers as
though it's kind of like this
yeah this this collective you know uh
entity with with a single brain and a
single single value system but i i think
at the time that's not the way they uh
not the way any of them saw it so
roughly there's two camps and they map
onto the rationalist versus
traditionalist empiricist dichotomy that
i proposed earlier
and the
so on the one hand you have
real revolutionaries like uh jefferson
and payne these are the people who burke
was writing against these are the people
who supported the french revolution so
when you say real so when you say pain
you're referring to revolutionaries in a
bad way like this is a problem these are
people who will say
history up until now has
has been you know like with with
descartes but applied to politics
history up until now has been
you know just a story of ugliness
foolishness stupidity and evil
and uh if you apply reason
we'll all come to
roughly we'll all come to the same
conclusions you know and pain writes a
book called the age of reason and the
age of reason is a manifesto for
here is the answer to political and
moral problems throughout history we
have the answers and it's in the same
school as russo's uh the social con no
you don't like that
not at all i thought it was like i think
they're the opposites okay so let me
just throw in a question on uh jefferson
and payne
do you think
america would exist without those two
figures
so like uh how how important is spice
in the uh in the flavor of the dish
you're making i don't want to try to run
the counter factual i don't you know i
don't have confidence that i know the
answer to the question but it's so much
fun
you know what i'm gonna offer something
that i think is more fun more fun than
the counter factual is
america had two revolutions not one okay
at first there is a revolution that is
strongly spiced with
this kind this kind of rationalism
and then there's a 10-year period after
the declaration of independence there's
a 10-year period under which america has
a constitution its first constitution
which today they call the articles of
the confederation but there's a
constitution from 1777.
and that constitution is
based on in a lot of ways on the hottest
new ideas it has
instead of the traditional british
system with a division of powers between
you know an executive and a bicam camera
legislature instead instead of that
traditional english uh model which most
of the states had is their governments
instead of that they say no we're gonna
have uh one
uh elected body
okay and that body that congress it's
going to be the executive it's going to
be the legislative it's going to be it's
going to be everything and it's going to
run as a big committee these these are
the ideas of the french revolution you
get to actually see them implemented in
uh in pennsylvania in the pennsylvania
constitution and then and then later in
the national assembly in france it's a
disaster the thing doesn't work it's
completely made up it's not based on any
kind it's it's neither based on
historical experience nor is it based on
historical custom on what people are
used to and what what they succeed in
creating with this first constitution is
it's wonderfully rational but it's a
complete disaster it doesn't allow the
raising of taxes it doesn't allow the
mustering of troops it doesn't allow
giving orders to to soldiers to fight a
war
and if it if that had continued if that
had continued to be the the the the
american constitution america never
would have been an independent country
they aren't willing to do that counter
factual
what happens uh during those years
where uh where uh washington and jay and
knox and hamilton and morris there's
like this group
of conservatives they're mostly
soldiers and lawyers others in
washington most of them are from you
know from northern cities
and this group is much more conservative
than uh than the uh then the tom paine
and and jefferson school you some some
historians some historians call them the
nationalist party uh historically they
give up the word nationalism and they
call themselves the federalists but
they're basically the nationalist party
what does that mean it means on the one
hand that their goal is to create an
independent nation independent from
britain but on the other hand
they believe that that they already have
uh national
legal traditions the common law the the
forms of government that have been uh
imported from from britain and of course
christianity which they consider to be
you know part of their inheritance
this this federal federalist party
is the conservative party
these are people who are extremely close
in in ideas to burke and these are
people who wrote the constitution of the
united states the second constitution
the second revolution in 1787
when washington leads the establishment
of a new constitution which you know
maybe technically legally it wasn't even
legal under the old constitution but it
was democratic and what it did is it
said we're going to take what we know
about
english government what we've learned by
pl applying english government in the
states we're going to create a national
government a unified national government
that's going to muster power in its
hands enough power to be able to do
things like fighting wars to defend a
unified people
those are conservatives now it's
reasonable to say
um
well look there was no king so how
conservative could they be but i think
that's a reasonable question
but don't forget that the american
colonies the the english colonies in
america by that point had been around
for 150 years they'd written
constitutions they had already adapted
for an entire century adapted the
english constitution to local conditions
where there's no aristocracy and there's
no king
you know i think you can see that as as
a positive thing on the other hand they
have slavery that's an innovation that
that's not english
so it's a little bit different from the
english constitution but those those men
are conservatives they make the the
minimum changes that they need for the
to the english constitution and and they
they largely replicate it which is why
uh the jeffersonians hated them so much
they call them apostates they say
they've betrayed uh uh equality and
liberty and fraternity by adopting an
english-style constitution
so i would imagine euron you would put
emphasis of the success of the key ideas
at the founding of this country
elsewhere
at the at the freedom of the individual
so the uh yeah what's the tradition of
the british empire i mean the one thing
i agree with yom is is is the fact that
yes the founding fathers were not a
monolith i mean they argued they debated
they disagreed they they wrote against
each other i mean jefferson and adams
for decades didn't even speak to each
other though they did make up uh and and
and had a fascinating fascinating
relationship you and i are making up
tonight
it's like the founding fathers
uh you know there's there's this massive
debate and and discussion
but i don't i don't agree with the
characterization of pain and jefferson i
don't think it's just to call them
rationalists because i don't think
they're rationalists people who've
looked at history at the problems in
history and and remember this is the the
18th century and they
uh
were coming out of 100 years earlier
some of the bloodiest wars in all of
human history were happening in in
europe
many of them over religion um
you know they had seen what was going on
in in france and other countries where
people were with people who were
starving uh and where kings were
frolicking in in palaces in spite of
that
uh
they were very aware of the relative
freedom that the british tradition
had had given englishmen i think they
they knew that they understood that um
and i think they were building on that
they were taking the observation of the
past and trying to come up with a more
perfect system
you